collège rostand argentan ici comme dans
n'importe quel établissement à l'heure
des parties endiablées de fou l'écart
son règne encore en maître dans la cour
de récré même si ici ou là on voit
surgir quelques courageuses pour aller
taquiner le ballon avec les footings ça
se voit peut-être a pour patron sur le
terrain dans la course aux quarts très
les garçons dans un coin les filles dans
son coin
voilà le fait d'avoir une option le
regard des garçons va tellement changé
aussi un peu et ils vont prévoir que les
fils avoue s'y joue le foot depuis la
rentrée l'établissement rené associé au
club d'argentan propose une option
uniquement réservé aux filles à raison
de deux heures par semaine
ces trois heures trente de football
intégré dans l'emploi du temps de ces
adolescentes de la 6e à la 3e
tu as une section sportive badminton
donc on a calqué
l'emploi du temps dessus les élèves sont
regroupés dans une classe par niveau
donc
en terme d'emploi et en ça ne pose
aucune difficulté majeure
et puis on a dégagé des moyens pour un
professeur pour qu'il puisse suivre
cette classe zoé juin julie pour cette
première aventure scolaire dans
l'univers du ballon rond 24 collégiens
ont ainsi répondu à l'appel non non pas
du tout et puis j'aime pas ça donne
aujourd'hui quand je les voyais à la
télé franchement voilà quand vous allez
monter régulier leur prêter je demander
mais pourquoi il désormais les voilà
donc lancé pour une année scolaire en
terrain inconnu
un trajet de courte durée effectué à
pied juste le temps pour elle de
traverser la route qui sépare le collège
du stan c'est pas mal parce que le
terrain soit côté m6 a l'avantagé si on
a eu vingt minutes de marche chinois
peut pas fonctionner aussi bien un à
cinq minutes du vestiaire des filles se
change en dix minutes après on
commençait à se vider l'océan ça se fait
en trois parties aujourd'hui comme
souvent tout au long de l'année
deux fois par semaine un duo
d'entraîneurs va ainsi encadré le groupe
autre petit détail de taille qui est ce
qui n'est pas licencié dans un club de
foot sur 24 filles une seule évolue en
club
autant dire alors que les séances seront
donc consacré à l'initiation
on savait qu'avec la coupe du monde
féminine ça les fait un buzz et qu'on a
les reins du monde mais à ce point-là
connais 23 que se motiver c'est vrai que
ça fait plaisir c'est aussi peut-être
que les fissions demande d'une pratique
sportive au collège autre que le ps et
du coup bah c'est hyper intéressant pour
nous tous a baladés
il faut être concentré à batimat au pied
gauche après à un moyen terme
l'option foot au collège pourrait même
s'avérer payante pour le club d'argentan
porteur du projet tu là pour faire le
relais auprès de nos éducateurs auprès
de nos dirigeants pour pour faire le
relais de nos filles qui sont collège
qui vont venir peut-être essayer une
séance ou deux peut-être après intégrer
le club entre lieu autre collège de ma
direction le sud manche à brécé en
immersion au sein de la section féminine
labellisée par la fédération française
de football et c'est la seule en
normandie
[Musique]